under this administration
we've put forward 36 billion dollars to
find a vaccine and we're hopeful that
we'll have that by the end of the year
and it's this president who's teared
down bureaucratic barriers to pave the
way
up for america to work its way through
covent 19.
the trump administration pushing to find
a coronavirus vaccine the president
predicting there could be a breakthrough
by
end of year kristin fischer is live at
the white house on that for us hey
kristen
hey sandra well over the weekend
president trump said that
he believes the united states will have
a therapeutic
and or vaccine for the coronavirus long
before the end of the year
but the person in charge of the agency
that is he's essentially the person that
would approve this vaccine
doctor stephen hahn he says that it is
very difficult if not impossible to put
a timeline on it
i can't predict when a vaccine will be
available our solemn promise the
american people
is that we will make a decision based
upon the data and science on a vaccine
with respect to the safety and
effectiveness of that vaccine
and dr hahn was also asked to defend
another claim that the president made
over the weekend
that 99 percent of coronavirus cases
are harmless dr han declined to do so
but the white house chief of staff
did this morning
i don't even know that it's a
generalization when you start to look at
the stats and look at all the numbers
that we have the amount of testing that
we have
the vast majority of people are safe
from this
as the number of coronavirus cases in
the u.s continues to spike
the race for a vaccine has become
increasingly urgent
the white house has been working to
expedite a vaccine under operation warp
speed but
despite that effort dr anthony fauci
says it will be early winter at the
earliest
before it is known if any vaccines
currently in development
are safe and effective now this morning
chief of staff mark meadows also said
that president trump will likely be
announcing
several executive orders this week on
immigration
manufacturing drugs prescription drug
prices
and china he says that you know hey if
congress is going to take
this long break over july then it is up
to president trump
to fix these things and he's going to
try to do that so sandra watch for that
a little bit later this week we will
indeed kristen fischer at the white
house for us kristin thank you